this is the sky king paper airplane it
was designed by a Japanese man named
taco toda and about four months ago he
used a modified version of this to set
the Guinness record for longest paper
airplane flight duration so today I'm
going to show you how to fold your own
okay so it starts out just like a
regular paper airplane you fold it in
half lengthwise and then you fold in the
front corners now next what you want to
do is pull the nose back towards the
tail weave about an interest room at the
back and then we're going to do the same
thing again where we fold the corners in
now this time we're not going to keep
the koehlers folded in we're going to
actually unfurl them and then fold the
corners in this way it's kind of a
reverse direction compared to what we
would usually do in a paper airplane and
then we'll fold these in yet again
forming is really sharp triangles now
once we're here we're going to start
working on the actual nose of the
airplane so first you'll fold the tip in
to this inside part of this triangle
right where my index finger is
and what that does is it creates a
crease that we're going to use
momentarily fold this out so the
underside is visible and using this
crease that we just created we're going
to fold the tip in again to create
another triangle a really small triangle
up front okay
so we have this little triangle opening
up here we'll open it up to create this
little kind of pouch that we're going to
flatten out along the creases to create
a little diamond like this so when you
look at it you have this diamond t.i now
our next step is we're going to pull the
tip of this diamond down so that there's
a folds halfway down you're going to use
this later as a reference for where to
fold your wings down and then we will
flatten it out here take the other end
flatten around to the other side so when
you look at it head-on
the paper is kind of flat again next
using this fold that we just created
would pull down the wings on either side
try to keep it straight with the edges
we're going on one side flip it around
do it again here
so we're almost done with the plane it
looks like a real paper airplane we have
it folded down like this we'll pull the
edges of the wings up to create flaps on
either end try to keep these symmetrical
then when we open it up make sure these
things are standing up and then it's a
final step you can put in what it called
elevators these are little folds that
help with stability and directions some
people actually cut the airplane to
create these flaps but the designer of
this particular paper airplane only
folds his airplanes so we're just going
to do the same thing crimp it a little
bit so it kind of sticks up in the back
and that's it there's your sky king
you